on jette les objets facilement parce
qu'il ne signifie rien pour nous
tous liens et créer avec les objets fait
que souvent les a mais davantage
des formats du problème environnement
ate ans et qu'on ne respecte plus les
objets
là qu'un petit bouquet carrasso évoqué
la couleur n'est plus à la mode on le
jette on en rachète alors qu'on comprend
pour le tout ce que ça implique de créer
des objets
[Musique]
et quand tu aimes davantage les objets
ben quand ils vont briser de soi c'est
de les réparer une soit 6,2 les restos
rue puis je pense qu'à long terme
disons qu'on devra avoir de beaucoup
d'objets pour acheter moins
[Musique]
je me considère comme un métallurgiste
artistique la coutellerie pour moi est
un prétexte pour faire de l'exploration
de la matière je suis quelqu'un qui ne
recherchent pas du tout la formule
gagnante
ça m'intéresse pas de trouver une
formule d'un modèle que tout le monde
est impliqué qui se produiraient
facilement et tout même ce modèle s'est
vendu très bien j'ai des très bons comme
anvers mais je vais quand même faire
quelque chose d'extrêmement différents
le couteau suivant le but ultime c'est
pas l'objet que j'ai fait le saut c'est
un moyen pour pour espérer une variable
[Musique]
c'est moi que je sculpte d'un certain
sens
euh je me rends compte à rebours qu'une
des meilleures choses qui m'est arrivé
dans ma vie c'est d'avoir fait une
dépression
je me suis enfermée chez moi pendant
presque un an maintenant je me suis
belge je n'ai plus rien dans la vie
enfin plus grand chose ne m'intéressait
[Musique]
massa m'a demandé mais qu'est ce qui
manque le corps humain
je me suis rendu compte que karim et moi
[Musique]
le shit boulimique de travail chez
boulimique de création la vie à
l'atelier me donner un certain équilibre
entre vie sociale et la solitude la
suite de prendre part importante dans ma
vie c'est beaucoup ce qui a développé
mon art du bonsaï honore tous deux
solitudes et deux de contemplation
muschick atteint de très contemplatif
il ya beaucoup notre peau morphisme
quand on parle de bonsaï on parle
beaucoup de torture des arbres personne
ne parle jamais de torture du gazon
qu'on le court à toutes les semaines
pour lui enlever cette idée lot de
projets tous que cet argument il s'en
tirait sur le coupé un doigt ou une
moins on voit à quel point la taille
d'un arbre le stimule au niveau des
bourgeons on se rend compte que il n'y a
pas de tortures réellement dans cette
intervention lola comme un gazon frais
coupés ils poussent beaucoup plus
rapidement que sont laissés à lui aussi
mais sa croissance et on dirigeants tout
sa croissance
plus ils poussent plus son système
racinaire se développe il ya aucune
technique pour que la barre est de
pousser
[Musique]
pour quelque chose de très
rafraîchissant de penser que l'oeuvre de
vivre indépendamment de l'artiste parce
que le couteau c'est quelque chose de
plus dominateur de ma part je rien qui
se rajoute si c'est pas ma volonté
alors j'aime bien ces deux démarches le
diamètre à la pause
[Musique]
e
la passion du terroir au québec se
développent de beaucoup beaucoup depuis
quatre cinq ans on commence à se rendre
compte que les tous les grands
déplacements internationaux polluent
énormément encourage les gens à manger
local à être fiers de nos matériaux
locaux
simona bon au magazine star tu as tu eu
quelque chose avec du vieux du vieux
métal
depuis plusieurs années je j'utilise des
morceaux du pont de québec les boulons
du pont de québec récupération c'est
exactement le même asik morceaux de
métal qu'on l'achète au magasin c de
même alliage esthétiquement c'est la
même chose mais symboliquement c'est pas
du tout la même chose
le frère ancien d'extérieur ça vient de
saut il manque les voûtes à convaincre
oui c'est en fait cela c'est après ce
que les bateaux étaient attachés ça
vient d'un vieux qu'eux et qu'on
pourrait faire sentir mais tant mieux le
métal d'ici le nickel de glam puis de
ses maisons en bois
moi j'ai choisi noyer noir parce que
c'est le bois le plus fort c'est comme
au québec je trouve qu'il faisait un
gros contraste plus intéressant avec
l'autre vu une écorce une peau de lyon
une quinzaine d'années ont presque
personne utilise des matériaux locaux
le kick c'était d'avoir de l'esbm de
l'ivoire ce qui est ce qu'ils venaient
d'ailleurs était beau et bon là j'ai
commencé à beaucoup aidé ces matériaux
du québec
donc les vouant quant au québec ou au
début c'était extrêmement difficile à
vendre
le marché se développer tranquillement
d'une certaine fierté d'acheter local
on n'a pas parlé de tami non le timing
j'ai abandonné votre prêt parfait pour
servier à lula
[Musique]
c'était
c'est le grand jour j'ai très hâte de le
voir là je te fais des préliminaires oui
c'est ça tellement il faut l'ouvrir
vas-y il m'a d'octo bois pour la cuisine
ouais
comparativement à des trucs qui sont
très près pour ces industriels sait qu
on a une histoire
c'est du métal du bois du machin qui ça
a été fait ou c'est pas prévu pour
briser puis si ça brise c'est réparable
parce que c'est fait par la main de
l'homme
non mais c'est fait par là même de
l'homme c'est ça que je veux dire c'est
comparativement mettant un couteau qui
est faire l'industrie mais ça tu leur
est pas parce que le prix est tellement
bas que ça sert à rien de le réparer tu
prends mon cher jacques rousseau dans la
machine qui le nom c'est ça mais n'y a
pas d'histoire non plus
[Musique]
le couteau you rien qui est imposé c'est
une page blanche
l'art du bonsaï les bana où il faut voir
comment on peut améliorer au mieux une
forme qui est déjà imposée quand on va
faire à madrid on absout pour cueillir
des arbres qui ont un potentiel de
transformation au bonsaï
on va cueillir un tronc d'arbre en fait
la position des branches est assez peu
importante on peut les déplacer pour
greffer des trucs on peut tendre le bois
mais le tronc lui moment on peut pas le
modifier tant que sow
[Musique]
voilà
ça c'est très joli vraiment très joli
style japonais ont dit socam qui veut
dire être on double en programmant sur
une souche commune ici alors je couche 1
min 38 au tour gérer plus facilement
penser qu inspire à côté sans jamais le
voir c'est un peu comme c'est lui qui
m'avait croit aux riffs nommé sévin de
lors d'une rencontre avec quelqu'un
d'impressionnant
c'est quelque chose de bon puis parce
que mes mouvements je dirais le on se
trouve et voilà le fin juin est en
parfaite santé
donc oui aujourd'hui lundi plaisir
partagé mon existence avec ceux avec ce
tableau à l'avenir
[Musique]
non mais c'est un lien maison